l'altro giorno mi sono svegliato alle 7
sono usato una sveglia satellitare
perché doveva assolutamente svegliarmi
in orario mi sono messo a preparare la
colazione quindi ho acceso la tv ho
controllato le ultime notizie sulla
siena poi mi sono seduto e
ho ascoltato un po di musica o io
ascolto un canale jazz americano tramite
una radio che si collega via satellite
prima di uscire
ho controllato le previsioni del tempo
lo sapere se potevo uscire in auto
oppure potevo prendere la moto sono
andati in aeroporto sono salito in aereo
mi sono seduto l'aereo arrivato in quota
partito il pilota automatico io ho
chiuso gli occhi e mi sono svegliato a
boston a boston passo il controllo dei
passaporti prendo il telefono chiama in
ufficio per sapere se andava tutto bene
il segnale era perfetto senza ritardi
lui sto raccontando la mia giornata
perché è una giornata particolare
probabilmente molte delle vostre
giornate sono molto più eccitanti però
c'è un punto un punto in comune con la
mia giornata con le vostre e
probabilmente quelle giornate di tutte
la maggior parte della tecnologia che
noi usiamo tutti i giorni arriva dallo
spazio arriva da quegli oggetti che
volano sopra le nostre teste che si
chiamano satelliti quindi noi dipendiamo
molto dalla tecnologia satellitare
peccato che questo potrebbe presto
sparire
quello che vedete è uno scontro tra due
satelliti un satellite americano
telecomunicazioni e un satellite russo
questo 7 satellite russo vagava nello
spazio da diverso tempo completamente
incontrollato questo scontro avvenuto
nel 2009 ha generato una nuvola di
frammenti che ad esso copre interamente
lo spazio orbitare attorno alla terra
questi frammenti viaggiano a 30.000
chilometri all'ora in realtà non è stato
l'unico oggetto inviato nello spazio
incontrollato ce ne sono più di 6mila
satelliti cui solo 900 oggi funzionano
tutti gli altri sono lì incontrollati
che vagano attorno alla terra e prima o
poi potrebbero anche cadere sulla terra
allora è chiaro che la probabilità che
questi oggetti cadendo vadano a colpire
le nostre teste o un infrastruttura
critica tipo una diga una centrale
elettrica la proprietà è molto molto
bassa oggi quasi inesistente ma
chiaramente noi continuiamo a lanciare
satelliti nello spazio senza
preoccuparci che cosa potrebbe succedere
e quindi questa probabilità continuare
ad aumentare
se vi state chiedendo come
potuto succedere come abbiamo fatto a
creare questo strato di immondizia nello
spazio ma in realtà è esattamente come
abbiamo fatto sulla terra abbiamo
cominciato a lanciarli abbiamo detto beh
tanto lo spazio è grande ci penserà
qualcun altro
e alla fine ci troviamo in una
situazione di questo tipo
e vedete questi oggetti si incrociano
tra di loro un po come il traffico in
india che vedete sullo schermo con
un'unica differenza le auto possono
frenare per evitare la collisione
i satelliti non possono farlo
e se non facciamo nulla si creerà una
sorta di reazione a catena ogni flash
rosso che vedete nel filmato è una
collisione tra tra oggetti nello spazio
che creerà una nube talmente densa da
distruggere tutti i satelliti attorno
alla terra è di nuovo anche qui c'è una
similitudine molto chiara quello che
vedete un fiume come un sacco di
immondizia questo fiume che una volta
dava acqua che poi veniva utilizzata per
i rubinetti questo film ha adesso oggi è
inutilizzabile anche lo spazio potrebbe
diventare totalmente
inutilizzabile grazie a questa nube di
detriti che impedirebbe il lancio di
nuovi satelliti per per generazioni
chiaramente un problema
è un problema perché questo significa
perdere la possibilità di fare attività
umane nello spazio per il futuro per
sempre quindi diventerà addirittura non
conveniente farlo anche per chi oggi
invece nello spazio comincia a fare
attività di business chiaramente ci sono
ci sono delle soluzioni dal mio punto di
vista il primo passo che bisogna
compiere per risolvere questo problema è
fare in modo di arrestare
l'aumento sistematico di concentrazione
di questi oggetti morti inutili attorno
alla terra ed è proprio questo che sto
facendo io con l'azienda che ho creato
tre anni fa e che si chiama di orbit di
orbit fa costruisce un
un motore è un motore intelligente che
si installa sui satelliti prima di
mandarli in orbita quando questo
satellite arriva nello spazio qui vedete
qualche immagine
il satellite può fare quello che deve
fare e noi non interagiamo con la vita
operativa del 7 reti ma quando il
satellite finisce il proprio carburante
o per qualsiasi ragione dovesse
spegnersi all'improvviso il nostro
motore può prendere il satellite e
dirigerlo verso terra in modo
assolutamente controllato e rapido
oppure parcheggiarlo in un'orbita
lontano dalla terra in attesa che poi in
futuro con una tecnologia che oggi non
c'è possa essere recuperato e riciclato
direttamente nello spazio
allora questa idea che vi può sembrare
fantascientifica
in realtà non è molto diversa da molte
delle idee che sono sicuro molti di voi
hanno in un cassetto in attesa di
trovare diciamo l'occasione giusta
il coraggio di metterla in atto e questa
è questa idea in realtà è nata molto
tempo fa è nata perché io voglio
realizzare un sogno il mio sogno è il
mio sogno è quello di andare nello
spazio e quindi ho cominciato davvero
tanto tempo fa quando avevo 5 anni
quindi di fatto i cinque anni me li sono
portati dentro fino fino a poco tempo fa
e questa voglia di andare nello spazio
mi ha portato a fare concorso per
astronauta nel 2008 nel 2008 partecipo
c'erano diecimila partecipanti e quattro
posti c'erano amici che mi dicevano ma
ma cosa ci provi quattro posti e cioè
però quattro posti ci sono qualcuno
verrà scelto quindi perché non io a un
certo punto avanti nella selezione
arrivo tra tra i primi 100
e qualcosa partecipanti lancerà tutto ma
arriva questa lettera dall'agenzia
spaziale europea che mi dice caro
ingegnere rossettini e stato un piacere
averla con noi ritenuti 3 10 anni magari
sarà più fortunato
ero fuori dal programma quindi dovevo
trovare un altro modo di andare nello
spazio
ma c'era il problema dei detriti
spaziali se fosse diventato astronauta
in modo nell'altro mi avrebbero infilato
in qualche navicella e spedito su ma
così se devo andarci da solo con tutti
questi oggetti che ruotano con il
rischio che spetta di non poter più
accedere allo spazio dovevo fare
qualcosa
e quindi mi sono messo seriamente a
mettere insieme diciamo concetti di
ingegneria aerospaziale e concetti di
sostenibilità strategica non volevo
trovare una soluzione che fosse punitiva
tipo le multe volevo trovare una
soluzione che permettesse che oggi
diciamo crea il problema
fare in modo che possano risolverlo
portandosi a casa un vantaggio economico
ma soprattutto che tutta la società ne
potesse beneficiare e da lì è nato il
concetto di dior bit peccato che a quel
tempo io stavo facendo il dottorato di
ricerca l'avevo appena finito e come
sapete i dottorati di ricerca in italia
sono ricchissimi quindi non aveva una
lira
ho provato anche ad andare in banca
chiedendo soldi per finanziare
l'attività ma all'epoca non sapevo che
le banche non fanno questo di lavoro e
quindi ho messo diciamo l'idea in un
cassetto e mi sono messo a fare altro un
anno dopo per caso ho incontrato questa
borsa di studio si chiama fulbright best
è una borsa di nonostante il nome
diciamolo origine americana è
sponsorizzata da aziende ed enti
italiani
e mi ha permesso di andare in silicon
valley a studiare business quindi
infervorato prendo vado in silicon
valley silicon valley ci sono un sacco
di soldi un sacco di investitori pronti
a credere nelle idee innovative quindi
la prima settimana è arrivato mi
precipito subito da un investitore mi
siedo al tavolo prendo la mia
presentazione bellissimo il mio bel
motore prima slight secondo slide questo
signore si alza prenderci aiuterà il
cellulare dal tavolo esce dalla stanza
io aspetto dopo un quarto d'ora arriva
la segretaria mi dice guardi dovrebbe
uscire dalla stanza dicono no so sto
aspettando è uscito veramente sta
telefonando fosse andato in bagno
non ho mai capito la riunione è finita
io sono un po sorpreso mi alzo me ne
vado non avevo capito quindi pochi
giorni dopo esco a cena con un altro
investitore a quel punto vado a cena con
quello che poi sarebbe diventato il
futuro il mio socio renato andiamo in un
ristorante italiano ovviamente paghiamo
noi
questo investitore mi ascolta dopo
cinque minuti e gli racconto
l'idea mi fanno guarda così come me la
stai dicendo
lasciamo stare parliamo di cibo italiano
dopo tre ore a parlare di cibo italiano
e vi posso assicurare che l'italiano
c'era solo il nome torno a casa ea quel
punto a quel punto avevo capito
l'idea così com'era non andava bene
l'idea non basta è un buon punto di
partenza ma non basta dovevo imparare a
rendere l'idea prima soluzione poi
prodotto e quindi mi sono messo a capo
fitto mi svegliavo alle 4 del mattino
andavo a fare colazione 30 miglia di
distanza con un altro gruppo di sbandati
come me che volevano fare azienda
cercando di capire quali erano i
problemi comuni e come risolverli
arrivare a qualcosa di concreto è stato
un periodo veramente di studio matto e
disperatissimo
matto dicevo studio di matto e
disperatissimo che mi ha portato alla
fine in nasa in asia è stato sicuramente
un bel periodo
alla fine sono uscito con un piano
industriale serio questo piano
industriale mi sembrava buono però detto
vali diamolo l'ho spedito ad una compiti
ad una competizione internazionale che
poi ho scoperto essere una delle più
grandi al mondo primo premio un milione
di dollari quindi un sacco di soldi
alla fine spedisco questa questa piano
industriale e arriviamo in finale quindi
di orbitano mia non azienda ancora
arriva in finale peccato che dovevamo
essere io e renato due persone minimo
tale giorno entro mezzogiorno presenti a
huston ma il nostro visto americano
scadeva giorno il giorno prima quindi
dovevamo uscire dal paese ritornare di
nuovo negli stati uniti e prima che
scadesse diciamo il termine di
presentazione quindi prendo prendo i
miei bagagli vado in europa aprendo il
primo volo per houston ritorno a huston
prendo il telefono chiamò subito renato
renato renato dove sei lui dice luca mi
sono innamorato sono in canada
renato casualità domani a mezzogiorno tu
devi essere qui altrimenti altrimenti
veniamo squalificati insomma alla fine
lo convinco noleggia un'auto aspetta il
confine perché doveva aspettare la
mezzanotte per passare il confine prende
quindi in auto con la sua diciamo nuova
nuova meta che poi è ormai è già
diventata vecchia mappa quindi
attraversa praticamente mezzi stati
uniti per arrivare ius nel frattempo io
stavo dicendo di giudici non ho
tranquilli renato è già qui ma è un po
in disposto quindi arriverà non vi
preoccupate alla fine sale sul palco
esattamente quando stavano arrivando gli
applausi la fine della presentazione
quindi tutto bene non abbiamo vinto un
milione di dollari realtà abbiamo vinto
500 dollari ma soprattutto abbiamo vinto
la che un buon punto di partenza abbiamo
vinto la consapevolezza che l'idea
poteva davvero diventare prodotto perché
non siamo arrivati ultimi eravamo in
finale non siamo neanche arrivati ultimi
dei finalisti quindi a questo punto cosa
facciamo torniamo in italia e vi dico
non è stato facile c'è voluto un po
circa sei mesi per trovare qualcuno un
investitore che credesse nell'idea come
ci credevamo noi ea marzo del 2011
l'idea è diventata un'azienda un'azienda
che è partita da un pezzo di carta e
questo è stato il primo schizzo del del
nostro dispositivo pochi pochi mesi dopo
ha realizzato il primo motore e
l'attestato è sostanzialmente meno di un
anno dopo ha mandato in orbita il
cervello del del dispositivo che oggi è
sopra le nostre teste e che sta facendo
adesso un satellite vero grande più o
meno così dotato del nostro dispositivo
che verrà mandato in orbita e rimosso
dopo due mesi di operazioni in orbita e
questo sarà il primo satellite al mondo
rimosso in modo controllato e sicuro da
un'azienda italiana
quello che vi stavo per dire che in
realtà non è stato così facile come vela
sta raccontando le porte in faccia sono
state diverse abbiamo preso un sacco di
no e probabilmente ne riceveremo ancora
tanti però veramente io sono convinto
che siamo che stiamo andando nella
direzione giusta ogni mattina io vado in
ufficio e trovo 15 persone che ci
credono come me se non più di me che
passano il loro tempo con passione e
dedizione e quello che stanno facendo e
che adorano ogni minuto che passano a
lavorare su questo progetto
e allora e allora mi viene una
riflessione la nostra giornata 24 ore di
queste 24 ne possiamo più o meno 8
dormendo anche se il primo speaker e il
mago diceva che fa bene dormire però noi
non ci rendiamo conto dormiamo
passiamo un bel po di tempo seduti in
mezzo al traffico a fare le pulizie
domestiche a fare i compiti per casa
alla fine ci rimangono due tre ore di
tempo veramente libero in cui ci godiamo
il nostro tempo libero il resto del
tempo lo passiamo lavorando allora
perché non trasformare il tempo che
lavoriamo in un tempo che invece ci
piace in cui facciamo qualcosa che ci dà
soddisfazione e allora ne parlavo
l'altro giorno con un paio di amici che
mi dicevano stessi tour a fi facile tu
hai giocato tutto ti sei buttato però io
io devo pagare il mutuo della casa o una
famiglia o dei figli o una carriera non
s'è poi perdo tutto cosa succede però
riflettiamoci momento noi che siamo qui
in questa sala che ci possiamo
permettere di essere qui questa sera che
ogni tanto ci possiamo permettere
perfino un caffè al bar se anche
perdessimo la casa perdessimo il lavoro
la carriera saremo comunque parte di
quel 5 per cento delle persone più
fortunate al mondo
comunque quindi vale la pena fare quello
che ci piace vi lascio con una con una
frase è una frase che ho sentito per la
prima volta da un amico indiano quando
vivevo in oklahoma e questa fase dice
questo per colpire l'aquila delinerare
alle stelle se mi ri all'aquila colpirà
di un sasso
grazie